>> TONIGHT, WAS HE POISONED BY
PUTIN?
LOOK AT THIS.
ON THE LEFT, PUTIN'S FAUX, ONE
YEAR AGO.
ON THE RIGHT, SUCCESSFULLY
TODAY.
HIS LAWYERS, ARGUING TODAY, THE
FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE COUNTRY
OF GEORGIA, A LONG TIME PUTIN
ADVERSARY SAY THAT TEST SHOW
HEAVY METALS ON HIS BODY, AND
PUTIN IS BEHIND IT.
YOU WILL HEAR THE DETAILS IN
JUST A MOMENT.
TODAY, HE LOOKED EXTREMELY
FRAIL.
HE ATTENDED THIS COURT HEARING
REMOTELY.
IT WAS HIS FIRST PUBLIC
APPEARANCE IN MONTHS, AFTER HE
WAS IMPRISONED FOR CORRUPTION,
UPON RETURN TO GEORGIA, FROM
THE UNITED STATES.
SAAKASHVILI APPEARANCE, COMING
JUST AFTER THE UKRAINIAN
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY, PUBLICLY,
CALLED ON THE GEORGIA
GOVERNMENT TO RELEASE
SAAKASHVILI.
MIKHEIL SAAKASHVILI IS A MAN I
HAVE KNOWN FOR YEARS.
HE HAS APPEARED ON THE SHOW
MULTIPLE TIMES.
HE WAS A LOUD CHAMPION FOR
GEORGIA ON THE WORLD STAGE, HE
FOUGHT AGAINST PUTIN WHEN PUTIN
INVADED GEORGIA.
AND, HERE, THEY SAID IT WAS
HAPPENING HERE IN PRISON.
>> DO YOU RECALL, SPECIFICALLY,
A TIME YOU WERE BEATEN WHEN
THEY REMOVED YOUR WATCH?
>> YES, AT THAT TIME THEY WERE
CHOKING ME, AND STRANGLING ME.
THEY'RE REPEATING MY HANDS LIKE
THIS, SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
>> WERE THEY STEPPING ON YOUR
NECK?
>> THEY WERE STEPPING ON MY
NECK.
THEY DELETED THE VIDEO THAT
WOULD SHOW IT BETTER.
>> AFTER COVERAGE, IT WAS THERE
WITH MIKHEIL SAAKASHVILI STORY.
>> THIS IS WHAT HAS BECOME OF
ONE OF THE MOST INFLUENTIAL MEN
IN THE PAST SOVIET WORLD.
IT WAS AN UNIDENTIFIED FIGURE,
AND IN THE NATIVE GEORGIA, HERE,
IN PRISON.
THEY SAY THAT THEY ARE TRUMPED
UP.
AUTHORITIES RELEASED THESE
PICTURES IS WHAT'S CALLED,
QUOTE, A PIECE OF AGGRESSIVE
BEHAVIOR.
IT WAS A PRESIDENT THAT HAS
BEEN ON, OR OF HUNGER STRIKE,
DEMANDING BETTER MEDICAL CARE.
THIS WEEK, UKRAINE'S PRESIDENT,
VOLODYMYR ZELENSKYY, APPEALED
TO GEORGIA, TO GIVE HIM JUST
THAT.
>> PLEASE, MAKE A DECISION THAT
WILL SAVE HIS LIFE, THE
PRESIDENT SAID.
TRANSFER MIKHEIL SAAKASHVILI TO
ONE OF THE CLINICS IN UKRAINE.
AND OTHER EUROPEAN COUNTRY.
AMERICA.
>> THE NEW THORN IN PUTIN'S
SIDE, STANDING UP FOR THE
FIRST.
A YOUNG, AMERICAN TRAINED
LAWYER, IS TO UNSEAT GORGEOUS
LONG SERVING SENATOR BACK IN
2003.
THE SO-CALLED REVOLUTION IS THE
THOUGHT OF THE REGION'S ARMS.
IT IS A PROTEST THAT HAS
FOLLOWED.
>> IT IS FOR AS LONG AS
NECESSARY TO STOP MASS SCALE
FRAUD, AND RIGGING OF THE
ELECTION.
>> IT WAS THE FACE OF LIBERTY,
FLUENT IN MANY LANGUAGES,
CAUSING PANIC AT THE KREMLIN.
THE DARLING OF U.S. NEOCONS,
SAAKASHVILI SOON FOUND HIMSELF
AT WAR WITH RUSSIA IN 2008.
A BRIEF CONFLICT, IN WHICH
PUTIN SAID, HE WOULD HANG HIM
BY HIS BALLS.
HE DID NOT.
GEORGIA, AND ITS PRESIDENT,
SURVIVED.
BY 2013, SAAKASHVILI LEFT
OFFICE UNPOPULAR, AND PROTESTED
AGAINST, DESPITE THE WIDESPREAD
REFORM HE HAD IMPOSED ON
GEORGIA.
HE GOT A SECOND LEASE OF LIFE
WHEN HE LEFT FOR UKRAINE, BUT
IT WAS SWEET, THEN SUDDENLY
SOUR.
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT, PETROV
POROSHENKO, IN 2015, GAVE HIM
UKRAINIAN CITIZENSHIP SO HE
COULD GOVERN THE REGION AROUND
ODESSA.
BUT, QUICKLY, THEY FELL OUT.
SAAKASHVILI ACCUSED POROSHENKO
OF CORRUPTION, AND BEGAN AN
UGLY SERIES OF SCENES, ARRESTS,
AND PROTESTS, LEADING TO
SAAKASHVILI RETURN TO GEORGIA,
TO FACE TRIAL FOR ABUSE OF
POWER, AND HOSPITALIZATION
AFTER HUNGER STRIKES.
HIS RISE, AND FALL, A PARABLE
OF RUSSIA'S CONTINUED GRIP OVER
ITS EMPIRE.
NICK PATON WALSH, CNN, LONDON.
>> THAT, OF COURSE, WAS NICK
PATON WALSH WITH THAT
RECORDING.
NOW, I WANT TO BRING IN MOSSIMO
TO ANGELO, ONE OF SAAKASHVILI
LAWYERS, AND EDWARD SAAKASHVILI,
HIS SON.
EDWARD, LET'S START WITH YOU.
CAN WE SHOW THE SIDE BY SIDE OF
YOUR FATHER AGAIN?
JUST ONE YEAR AGO, RIGHT AFTER
HE WAS ARRESTED, COMPARED TO
HOW HE LOOKS TODAY.
IT WAS FRAIL, AND WEAK, AND
STARK FOR ANYONE FOR YOU.
IT WAS HARD TO SEE WHERE THEIR
FATHER COULD DO THIS.
>> IT WAS A REALLY AWFUL.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME, AND I
THINK WHAT IS DIFFERENT FOR ME
IS TO GET A CHANCE TO SEE THEM
IS HIDDEN BY THE PUBLIC MONTHS.
I HAD A CHANCE TO VISIT HIM TO
PRISON, IT WAS THE PAINFUL PART
THERE THAT HAD BEEN WATCHING
HIM, AND HIS SLOWLY DECLINED IT
IS IN THE LAST FEW MONTHS.
IN A WAY, AS SHOCKING AS THESE
IMAGES IS HOW AWFUL THIS HEALTH
IS, AND IT WAS UNDENIABLE, AND
IT IS MAKING INSINUATIONS AS
WELL, AND WHEN YOU SEE THIS
FOOTAGE IT WAS COMPLETELY
OBVIOUS, HOW FAR HE HAS
DECLINED.
AS SHOCKING AS IT IS, IT IS
OBVIOUSLY THE PRESSURE AS WELL,
AND THE OUTRAGE.
>> MUSLIM OF PLAYED THIS AUDIO
CLIP THAT SHE HAD SHARED ABOUT
THIS, AND IT IS ONE INSTANCE OF
ALLEGED ABUSE IT WAS WHAT IT
HAD BEEN ABOUT.
WHEN SHE WAS ASSAULTED, WHEN
SHE WAS TRANSFERRED FROM THE
PRISON, TO THE HOSPITAL, AND IT
IS PART OF THAT EXCHANGE.
HERE IT IS.
>> YOU ARE BEATEN?
>> YES, FOR SURE.
>> WHEN WERE YOU BEATEN?
>> WHEN THEY FORCIBLY TOOK ME
OUT OF THE CAR.
AND GEORGIA, LOFTIER IS NO
PROCEDURE, NO RIGHT, TO TAKE
SOMEONE TO A HOSPITAL.
IF THERE IS NO WRITTEN CONSENT.
>> IT IS PHYSICAL ABUSE,
SUSPECTED ASSAULT, RAPID
POISONING, RAPIDLY
DETERIORATING HEALTH AS EDWARD
IS TALKING ABOUT.
TO BE CLEAR, YOU BELIEVE THAT
PUTIN IS BEHIND THIS, RIGHT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
PEOPLE FORGET, BUT IN 2008,
PUTIN DID EXACTLY WHAT HE IS
DOING NOW IN UKRAINE, TO
GEORGIA.
UNDER COLOR OF DARKNESS, HE
INVADED GEORGIA.
JUST LIKE PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY
TODAY, IN UKRAINE, HE STOOD UP,
AND HE FOUGHT BACK.
BECAUSE OF THIS, THE KREMLIN,
AND PUTIN SPECIFICALLY, HE CAME
HIS ARCH NEMESIS, THE NUMBER
ONE ENEMY.
BECAUSE OF EVERYTHING THAT
SAAKASHVILI DID IN WESTERNIZING
THE COUNTRY, IT IS ADVERSE WHAT
PUTIN WANTED, AND KREMLIN
WANTED.
THEY TRIED TO ANNOUNCE TO THE
WORLD, AND HE FORESHADOWED
EVERYTHING IS DOING TODAY.
IT IS BRINGING A SOVIET
REPUBLIC BACK, AND THE NEXT
TERRITORIES THAT WERE
PREVIOUSLY PART OF THE SOVIET
REPUBLIC.
>> YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT YOUR
FATHER, OBVIOUSLY, WIN GEORGIA,
AND PUTIN WAS TO BLAME.
EVEN AFTER HE LEFT OFFICE, HE
SPOKE OUT WHENEVER HE COULD TO
WARN COUNTRIES ABOUT PUTIN.
HE WAS VERY VOCAL ABOUT IT.
HE RAISED HIS VOICE, AND HE
SAID THIS.
>> IT IS GOING TO INTIMIDATE.
THE ONLY THING THAT AMERICA
CANNOT AFFORD TO SHOW THE
RUSSIANS IS THAT AMERICA IS
WEAK.
THE ONLY THING PUTIN
APPRECIATES, AND EVERYONE KNOWS
THIS, IS SHEER FORCE.
>> YOU BELIEVE THAT PUTIN WAS
THREATENED TO THE WORLD, AND TO
EXPOSE THAT, HE WAS AT RISK OF
BEING PRISONED.
TO MAKE THAT, TO STAND UP FOR
THAT, JEWS HE HAVE ANY REGRETS
ABOUT SPEAKING, OUTDOOR ABOUT
RETURNING?
>> I WOULDN'T SAY HE HAS
REGRETS ABOUT SPEAKING OUT, I
THINK YOU VERY MUCH CONTINUES
TO STAND FOR WHAT HE ALWAYS
HAS.
BUT, AS FOR THE RETURN, I DON'T
WANT TO SPEAK FOR HIM, AND TO
SPEAK FOR THEM, IT WAS A
MISSTEP.
OBVIOUSLY, THE WRITING IS ON
THE WALL, BUT HOW THE GEORGIAN
AUTHORITIES ARE GOING TO REACT.
OBVIOUSLY, IT IS GOING TO BE
WAY WORSE THAN ANYONE WAS
EXPECTING, AND IT IS ONE THING
TO PUT SOMEBODY IN PRISON.
THAT'S TERRIBLE FOR THE FAMILY,
BUT, TO PUT SOMEBODY IN DISDAIN,
AFTER JUST A YEAR OF
IMPRISONMENT, QUITE OBVIOUSLY,
LITERALLY, IS ON THE VERGE OF
FIGHTING FOR THEIR LIFE.
THAT WAS OBVIOUSLY EXPECTED.
SO, I WOULD REGRET GOING BACK,
KNOWING THAT THAT IS WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN.
BUT, OF COURSE, AT THE TIME, IT
WAS DIFFICULT TO TELL.
>> MOSSIMO, WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
THESE HEAVY METALS, DO YOU KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT THESE, AND TO
LEAD YOU TO THINK ABOUT
POISONING, AND PUTIN WHICH, OF
COURSE, HAS BEEN ASSOCIATED,
AND ACCUSED OF POISONING IN THE
PAST?
WE KNOW THAT IS A FINGERPRINT
FOR RUSSIA'S TACTICS.
>> SURE.
WE KNOW THAT IS HOW THEY
OPERATE.
WHAT WE DID IS THE MEDICAL
EXPERTS, TOP MEDICAL EXPERTS IN
THE WORLD, NOBEL PEACE PRIZE
WINNERS, CONGRESSIONAL MEDAL OF
HONOR WINNERS, AND A WELL-KNOWN
TOXICOLOGIST.
SO, WHILE I WAS IN GEORGIA,
GETTING THE TAPES THAT WE
LISTENED TO EARLIER, MY
NEUROLOGIST WAS THERE WITH ME
AND WE TOOK SAMPLES.
IT IS HARRIS FROM SAAKASHVILI,
AS WELL AS A BIOPSY OF SOME OF
HIS FAT TISSUE IN HIS STOMACH.
WE SENT IT BACK TO A LAB IN THE
UNITED STATES FOR TESTING, IN
THOSE TESTS, ALONG WITH SOME OF
THE BLOOD TESTING RESULTS THAT
WE HAVE RECEIV